namor the sub-mariner is a pretty cool
comic-book character the first real
antihero in comics is punched Nazis
alongside Captain America has a wealth
of exotic powers and rocks a
form-fitting speedo diehard fans have
clamored for a name war movie for years
and with complex rights issues
surrounding the character reportedly
resolved it would seem like the time is
finally right but so far there's been no
sign of marvel's oldest superhero here's
a look at why Marvel won't give Namor a
movie too many worlds the Marvel
Cinematic Universe has explored other
dimensions distant worlds and even the
realms of the gods yet in all of those
travels and through all the world
threatening catastrophes we've seen
on-screen the only sign of name was
underwater Kingdom of Atlantis was a
brief easter egg on a map and that might
be for good reason once Marvel
introduces a race of superhuman berfo
led by a benevolent monarch fans are
gonna start wondering just why they
aren't you know doing anything
think about your buddy who always asks
why don't the Avengers just show up
every time you see a solo Marvel movie
with Namor in the picture everyone's
gonna ask why his army or fish people
don't swim in and save the day
and seriously he'll stop being funny
after the second time impossible
backstory Namor has a really cool origin
and it pretty much doesn't make any
sense in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
the Prince of Atlantis has supposedly
been around since World War two by
adding alongside cap and the invaders
but we know from Captain America the
First Avenger that no fish folk were
anywhere to be seen and explaining why
Namor hasn't even shown up at any point
in the last 75 years of MCU continuity
would be even trickier than Marvel's
efforts to thread the Winter Soldier
into historical events with shield and
Hydra both aggressively tracking
superhuman threats you think someone
would have noticed Namor and Atlantis
that's
point explaining why they have been
appeared on anyone's radar to this point
makes name or story that much more
difficult to tell
worst kryptonite ever in many ways our
superheroes are measured by the
weaknesses like the all-powerful
Superman being taken out by kryptonite
or imps from the fifth dimension
[Music]
but while kryptonite and wacky imps are
in relatively short supply
naima has a much more common weakness
err yes that's right
you see Namor gets his powers from water
so the longer he's out of water the
weaker and weaker he gets she I must
reach the sea if that's not enough he's
also weakened when he comes in contact
with polluted water which means is
pretty much doomed in today's world when
your hero needs to wear a Camelback in
order to keep from dying chances are is
gonna have a really short career
similarity to Aquaman speaking of
aquatic superheroes who gain the powers
from water one of the primary reasons
we'll never see a name or movie is the
DC is beating Marvel to the punch by
releasing a movie about Aquaman first
Arthur curry you can talk to fish
they're essentially the same character
super-strong Kings of Atlantis who can
communicate with marine life the only
difference is being that Aquaman is a
nerd and Namor is a stud it's ironic
that even though Aquaman is much better
known he's actually a total ripoff of
Namor who first appeared in comics pages
two years earlier still that's not going
to matter much to film audiences to them
name was going to seem like the copycat
fish and that's a big blow to his film
future the mutant problem while Marvel
chief creative officer Joe Quesada
stated in the summer of 2016 that Marvel
has regained the film rights to Namor
it's still complicated by other rights
issues you might have heard that story
set in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
can't mention mutants because the rights
to be enslaved at 20th Century Fox with
the x-men that's why the Avengers
version of Quicksilver was a miracle
created by Hydra and this is a problem
for Namor because Marvel Comics has long
marketed him as the world's first mutant
explaining his super-strength and flight
as genetic mutations combined with the
other issues surrounding his backstory
it seems like any version of Namor we
might see on screen would essentially
have to be an entirely different
character the Terrorism thing remember
when we call to Namor an antihero well
he also sometimes just via straight into
the realm of flat-out villainy in many
of these earlier stories he vented his
rage on arrogant surface dwellers by
randomly trashing their cities later
when he thought Atlantis had been
destroyed by nuclear testing he vowed to
destroy all of humanity attempting to
level New York using a giant walking
whale monster even after he learned his
people were actually totally fine one
time he even destroyed Black Panthers
home country of Wakanda just for funsies
named oz moral ambiguity is hardwired
into the characters appeal but superhero
cinema and Marvel movies in particular
don't leave much room for this kind of
nuance without it though Namor is just
another guy I'll be it a guy in a scaly
thumb which is fine for Magic Mike three
but maybe not so great for Avengers
three he makes for a better foil
historically Namor has been a great
character for others to play off of but
not all that interesting on his own he's
a cool rival for the affections of The
Invisible Woman and intriguing ally for
the x-men a complex villain for the
Avengers and a great foil for the
original Human Torch
but his solo adventures have been kind
of lackluster with these last comic book
series running just 11 issues before it
was canceled it's possible my
could find a way to use no more as a
member of attend like the Avengers or is
a villain for one of the TV shows or
something but as the lead in a solo
feature film if history is our guide
that seems unlikely the MCU that could
have been regardless of the
impossibility of his own movie it's fun
to imagine what Namor might have brought
to the Marvel Cinematic Universe it
would be cool to see Namor shouting
imperious Rex while repelling the next
round of alien invaders or punching
Thanos any stupid purple face alas the
name war movie is less likely to happen
than a gritty cinematic reboot of Howard
the Duck in the finest Marvel Comics
tradition these fans are simply left to
imagine what if thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel plus check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]